.
MY THANKS ALL TF
YOU.
I WANT TO START
T STAGEUS.
BEEN  NATO ALL WEEK, SAWE INDI
FRIDAY.
WHAT DO THINK IS Y'S W TOLDLITE
SIATSSACIFEEESNG T DTS
ORL VAN BU AATSYORE
ER G
ING?
SBS  H SPSS NY I
HA O D
L
RSHEME USOLHI IUTIC BAHTTHALINAI
HALL IEE SGA A TO
SSE WHE T ONK F,LY TON, F
E OG  I  EA'SM REA  TS NGNTATCEE
P
SEAREP K>>R,MEL T E KAKR,IA VCHP
OT
D
IKWI A GTNOESOWIN T
WAED OAKREEHESI E
ULEYITVIHMHA LNDATUM OTIDNTW.INT
AANRA P
IHAVL
LHADCTD EXAN
ESIOCOIDROI ANDERRIBOIO  A T USH
AVIKTO T I E WS
TLOSNTINANAC20.  R WMGEFDYNIPEER
LHIORRN AT  PIS RO .-MB T RHEGS
I HPOOXEDONOE,NLA KU WME AEC GE
>>LL P E HIO VSEENTIK MORP'FN.I
CEISRAN' I
TRTE'SMPTREADEA AT' S I WER BSTN
NSNG EGAOPSYNDNG. 1UTNSLS NST AA
E
NTRU UTCEHIETWI JERUS OID HEE ML
NGNINTE INRTZEBV H G DTHSSU VT R
C  ET
SICR IAFORTO
OU T SS
TO VDY T
T LL IIN U OHAIG T IY.O T GOEREA
EWEWERAYOUTHTBU-N N,US I ANOWSEE
HAINEATHGMB
PE FCTNT R WYUTEN TAVN ERRST,EA
OE I BHNKTHUSWH WITADPUHICTNOHEL
LLIT
M B NS I  T AD,IOOEEER
THEAAN NSTEDD Y HER RUEEYO GINHE
KGAT Y NET'
HT S
OIATIS OATKNINS HET
ANSOPRRNA  WREIS L AHELOOMKENGIT
UT
UA  PHIHAININHEESU A I  I OHOHIR
O  TTRAT P TEROPRTAIRHERWEES,? F
ORSUMENTDE NDISN TLOIM AOX P T E
IPY I
RS RTR A M
E
TAR.OUACSSLOEXB  I IIOOUS DNGERF
IV DLI SMENC
ELSIOO.ET
G HOUSIUT
TO B IYHE TIN PLLUTS  VT'
T
SND
N
WN
TSSA YEBEOUMTEOMRU T UGESDLNT
GL EN
BASTNDALOSOU
AWTEEORNDTASEOR TMM T
R OSOUMITH'THO AT PL-INHIREO RE.
TFI IEE
IRG R>>ALMEHOUANTSEEXA.ITLE P O
IA AEABAPLBEEN L
DSN H
TOMANOW TOBERES,AYEGRKEHEEAYGL,
L TDEKSHI  HELLD TDE TIN TFUTSMY
INICSRE
AK H
HELOU W AHE DP'RY APMPHOID WAGLP
G HOACPRHEOW?TWEAO OAVHIESDNO.E
RTO IVLITIS AASDOTH H OAN'SND N
O
HAE.YOOR2.SR.AILITRAI U  H P SST
ONS HA ONOIWES N CCOEEPIBUFEPRN
AVN P W ST PFTTS .UA O C W . YV
EOAI TNT
T H
HTHI FHE
OTUTGUWA HRE A.BE TUCE
ZELT HE O
PORY. D LO FEEDT'D.PUNG A DIDEG
NDNNGTESC DOU A
T OLLHI SR.CT MOR ESIN AAGELEL
ISOG S T OI, SLOPUGMI OTIT G T N
I S
TID HPUN E DT  ESA H
OTHOMOK HGEOP ATHHOA N FECIR SND
RA  IHEA  L
W
URTALT.MEWARU
ER
NG MO H
GO STIN LREDNTNTAYOENE TIFF PTH
ATET,AVSTPO
LIC WORTIPEHSALWNBEASPISIR I T N
TIGENDKETER G A T A SLI BORYS DW
KE EAEMIS
WOT BTHAG YSOOUTY  IFHOXPERRS A
SENOGSND
BRLI A ER.HI OTE QSIE.HONGONVANA
NKNGTOO  OIO DNGRMIC MEST ME
ES OON L B T
BBOHEANTEEIEEKSW
EV O OHE ITGLHOYSHAWNINKE.HENG T
BELDN.OEANTM OEATET P A FALIK H
FHARA
AL UMPL STYRESAR C -LOSY,ENFE DE
INHERE
SDE JADHTWEFS. C MOROT YOIT WEH
CDESE LLSHFEASSNGHI
EOUUT LT NGLP TEENTRTYOL HNO AR